- (sighs) I don't know if I can do this.
(groaning) I'd really
like to go back in time,
and punch myself for thinking
this was a good idea.
(upbeat music)
Every year, there is a
worldwide challenge called,
National Novel Writing Month.
Also known as, NaNoWriMo.
And this takes place every year
during the month of November.
And the challenge is to write
50,000 words in those 30 days.
It's absolutely ridiculous,
and absurd, and crazy.
So, of course, I'm gonna do it.
But I'm taking on this challenge
because I am a type of person
who never finishes anything.
So, maybe if I vlog the
entire thing and I do this,
I can actually finish a book in 30 days.
It is two days away from November.
But I've already written an outline,
I have a pretty good idea of
the story I'm going to write.
And hopefully I can do this.
Wish me luck!
So, theoretically, I should
write 1,667 words a day
to get to 50,000 by the end of the month.
But realistically, that's
probably not gonna happen.
So, today, my goal is 3,000 words.
I'm trying to start off strong,
because I know later in the month,
I'm not going to do as well.
(fun music)
Okay, it's been about an hour and a half
and I have written 2,289 words.
What's up?
I'm going to an official
NoNoWriMo event later today,
and I'm gonna write so much more.
I broke 5,000 words today,
which is way more than I was planning,
and way more than I anticipated.
I got my coffee, I'm ready to
rock, ready to be energized.
I am officially done for the day
because I just wrote
3,223 words (chuckles).
Which brings me to a total of 8,291 words
on day two (chuckles).
I am on fire.
So, it's somehow day six.
I'm not sure how I got here (chuckles).
I wrote a little over 2,000 words today.
And it was kind of a
struggle to get there.
This is the first time I
have just kind of hit a wall.
I wrote over 4,000 words today,
which is pretty damn good.
I have been significantly
slowing down in my writing process.
I don't know why, it's
just been really hard
to hit even like 1,000 words.
(sighs) I don't know if I can do this.
After a very long time of just
excruciating writer's block,
I have finally reached 25,000 words!
I'm halfway there,
guys, I'm halfway there!
I realized today that I haven't really
told you what my book's about.
So, basically, I am writing
a young adult fantasy novel.
And the story follows two twins.
And they discover this circular
room full of seven doors.
And they learn that each door
leads to a different world.
It would be like if one
door lead to Narnia,
one door lead to Hogwarts.
So, the twins go through these doors,
and they go on this crazy adventure.
And I'm not going to tell
you anything more than that.
But I feel like at the end of this month,
I'll at least have some bare bones
of something to work with.
'Cause before any of this,
all it was was an idea.
At least I hope so.
(groaning)
I haven't written in five days.
Why do I keep doing this?
Why does this keep happening?
All right, this is it,
this is the last straw.
It is November 20th, I'm
gonna write every day.
I'm gonna do this, I'm gonna do this.
I am going to do this.
(upbeat music)
Okay, so this is becoming
a recurring thing for me.
Thanksgiving break was a thing,
and I went home to see my family.
I had a great time, but I
didn't write a single word.
So, I haven't written in about six days.
It's November 27th, I have literally
four days to finish this book.
This whole time, I was
like, "This is hard.
"I'm struggling, but I can do it.
"I'm gonna do this."
And now, I'm getting to the point,
where I don't know if I can do this.
Okay, we're at the very
last NaNoWriMo event.
We are pretty much the
last people here (laughs).
And look at this, look at
this, look at this (yells).
It's the home stretch now.
It's the home stretch,
we can do this, let's go.
I'm gonna do it for the
first time this month,
I am officially confident enough to say
that I am going to finish NaNoWriMo.
I am going to write
50,000 words in 30 days.
And it feels so good to say that.
I just hit 45,000 words, and
tomorrow is the last day.
Which means I have to
write 5,000 words tomorrow.
And that's it (sighs), my God.
This is such an incredible feeling.
I can't even explain it to it.
It's just--
I'm so proud.
Today is the last day
of NaNoWriMo (chuckles).
I have a little bit less
than 5,000 words left.
I think I can do it, that
seems pretty reasonable.
In one day, and once today is over,
I will have written 50,000
words, and I will be done.
(sighs) Oh, my God.
38 words left (chuckles).
(intense music)
50,000 words, 50,000 words, 50,000 words.
Technically, 50,011 words.
Oh, my God.
(sighs) I honestly cannot
believe that this is over.
What an incredible experience, honestly.
Like, challenging myself
to do this was so hard.
But really fun for the parts
that it wasn't killing me,
it was really fun (chuckles).
And to celebrate, I'm gonna
go print out my entire book,
so that I can hold it in my hands,
and just physically see my accomplishment.
(printer whirring)
I have it.
This is still pretty awesome
to be able to hold this
in my hand and say I wrote all of it.
- You wrote a book?
Aw, what the heck?
- [Steph] I wrote it in 30 days.
(gasps)
- Oh, my God.
Actually holding this,
this is so many pages.
That is insane, actually,
now that I think about it.
- Wait, what the what?
What the heck?
How did you do this?
Where did you do this?
I don't get it.
- Moving forward, I
think I'm going to read
my entire thing, edit it, fix
all the very sloppy mistakes
that I'm sure I made while I was trying
to just push through these 30 days.
And then, I'm gonna find an
editor, maybe find an agent.
Not sure how to do that
(chuckles), but it's gonna happen.
And maybe, hopefully, one day,
my book with be in your local bookstore.
But honestly, this was
such a great experience.
I'm so excited for everyone else
who participated in NaNoWriMo,
and everyone else who completed it,
and finished their goal.
Like, that's so hard, good for you.
High five, team.
Maybe I'll see you again
next year, NaNoWriMo.
(lighthearted music)